degree candidates family members and
friends provost cotesworth faculty and
colleagues of the school of continuing
education and distinguished guests
welcome to the 2012 school ceremony
please receive it on this great occasion
we rejoice in the celebration of ideas
and of people who exhibit the classic
Columbia excellence extraordinary minds
brilliant scholarship and unparalleled
potential our coming together this year
marks sces 10th anniversary of its
founding as a school and the elaboration
of se es renewed mission to transform
knowledge and understanding in service
of the greater good which we defined is
a just compassionate and sustainable
global society we celebrate too and
coming together today advancements of
the schools vision for the future to be
a leading model of 21st century higher
education building domains of
cross-disciplinary expertise that give
rise to an advanced emerging and
evolving professions this occasion marks
the first year that Columbia will confer
degrees on 400 graduates yes
who hail from each of 13 the 13 SCE
Masters in Science degree programs we
also celebrate the launch of sces
innovative hybrid master's program
design which combines rigorous
residential experiences with highly
interactive online learning this model
gives SCE the capacity to connect
students faculty and alumni anywhere in
the world through robust social media
technologies and knowledge networks with
this design we are proud to created
Columbia's first low residency online
master's degree these new folk I
represent the convergence of remarkable
strands of change and innovation growing
as they do from our stewardship of
Columbia's core values and ideals those
of advancing learning at the highest
levels and teaching students to frame
their ideas within the context of the
larger society and SCE students embrace
and embody these principles in the
fullest sense allow me to share a few
examples Sarah Coulomb entered the
fundraising management program is event
manager for the American Cancer Society
and leaves as director of endurance
events for Children's Tumor Foundation
always a competitive athlete Sarah now
embarks on her most challenging event
yet Ironman competition and 99 days out
Sarah began offering a reason a day as
to why she was running with each day
dedicated to a child who is battling
cancer and whose story eshe story she
shares with social media prior to
joining the sustainability management
program and in its inaugural year John
David capuano spent most of his 11-year
career in operations and business
analytics at a fortune 200
pharmaceutical company as a student here
JD demonstrated his leadership strengths
as a founding member of the
sustainability management student
Association and during his studies he
also explored his entrepreneurial side
during his with advice from set
professor Satya jet Bose JD and fellow
student Samuel abay co-founded a new
venture closed-loop advisors a
sustainability strategy and operations
consultancy to which they will now be
able to devote themselves more fully
sahar molly's multicultural
american-iranian upbringing brings a
unique sensitivity perspective and
thoughtfulness to her graduate work in
negotiation and conflict resolution she
helped establish the association of
negotiation and conflict resolution
students an officially recognized
organization at Columbia which is now
thriving in the summer of 2000 yes in
the summer of 2010 sahar worked in
Burundi for a regional organization
doing peace building working in the
Great Lakes regions of Africa she will
continue her studies this week or this
fall at UC Berkeley's bolt school of law
where she will specialize in human
rights law Jessie Hendricks entered the
sports management program in the spring
of 2010 following his retirement for a
career in professional athlete at that
same moment Jessie knew exactly what he
wanted to do next provide mentoring and
leadership to student-athletes this
student population is required to
balance multiple and often competing
priorities but often not given the tools
to do so and frequently not given proper
guidance for life after competition
Jessie began the MS program volunteering
his energy and passion to colombia's
athletics program and he now graduates
as the university's full-time assistant
director for athletic enrichment
services
David De Luca earning his ms and
strategic communication combines his
creativity with passion for creating
positive social change during his
earlier media career as writer and
producer David created a Warren
award-winning advertisements for
companies including Nickelodeon dell
safe kids and target he recently
transitioned from the corporate world in
turn the nonprofit sector leveraging the
opportunity to choose a client and topic
he was passionate about for his capstone
project David was hired by his capstone
client immediately after completing his
degree he now serves as head of
campaigns at dosomething.org a nonprofit
organization with a commitment to youth
and positive social change and Catherine
all who graduates from the MS and
landscape design program developed a
design for the acclaimed PSAT for
rooftop project on the Upper West Side
her design integrated many aspects of
the extensive wish list provided by
students parents faculty and staff of
PAS 84 into a highly funk
multifunctional outdoor learning area
with a sharp focus on sustainability and
the effective engagement of students the
resulting design offers an outdoor
classroom vegetable garden rainwater
harvesting station and butterfly bird
and insect habitat Katherine will pursue
a career in landscape design in New York
City with a focus on sustainable and
ecological design practices and habitat
restoration SAE degree candidates these
few examples demonstrate that you
understand the power of Education to
change your lives and improve the lives
of others and you have chosen to make it
a priority despite the varied academic
career as you have pursued you each
embody a most powerful combination of
elements each of you came to Columbia
with purpose and urgency and a strong
sense of the problems facing the world
in the 21st century each of you brought
to Colombia a unique combination of
lectual talent maturity and a broad
spectrum of experiences and
accomplishments individually and
collectively you have enriched the
discourse in SE classrooms and
throughout the university more
importantly as you leave columbia you
leave knowing how to use your academic
intellectual gain to advance the public
good so on this glorious day we salute
you SCE students on your commendable
academic achievement thank you
and now it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce the twenty-second Provost of
Columbia University john h coatsworth
professor of International and public
affairs and of history Provost
cotesworth is a leading scholar of Latin
American economic and and international
history he developed a distinguished
record of scholarship and leadership at
national and international institutions
of renown as a member of the faculty at
the University of Chicago as a visiting
professor and Fulbright senior lecturer
at prominent institutions in Mexico
bueno SI de sandra dread as the monroe
Gutman professor of Latin American
affairs at Harvard University where he
was also the founding director of
Harvard's David Rockefeller Center for
Latin American Studies and the chair of
the harvard university committee on
human rights studies and just prior to
his Provost deol appointment as Dean of
Columbia School of International and
public affairs a position he held from
2008 until the beginning of this
academic year prestigious the stat
societies have honored Provost
cotesworth for his work including the
american academy of arts and sciences
and the john simon guggenheim foundation
i first met provost cotesworth in 2009
when he was Dean of sepa and he warmly
welcomed me to Columbia so it is now an
honor for me to present him to you the
graduating class of 2012 Provost
cotesworth
Thank You Dina bill meier have you ever
noticed that as you get older
introductions sound more and more like
obituaries longer'n was very generous
thank you a warm Columbia welcome to all
of you to their faculty to the Dean to
the graduating students but most of all
and here I think a round of applause is
in order to the family and friends and
loved ones who have stood behind you
during the hard times and the easy times
that it made possible for you to come to
this day
of all the graduation ceremonies this
week at Columbia this is my favorite I'm
deeply impressed with the graduates of
the School of Continuing Education
because you have recognized the value of
continuing your education and renewing
your knowledge and in that process you
have been reinventing yourselves and
your careers graduation is a significant
and meaningful event for all of us for
students it is an important signal that
you have successfully completed the
requirements of the degree for faculty
it is a signal that we have successfully
transferred the knowledge and skills of
our disciplines to the next generation
for family and friends it is an
opportunity to celebrate a milestone in
the life of a loved one for the
university it is the time when we
welcome yet another group of individuals
who up until now have been immersed in a
singular academic program into the wider
Columbia University Alumni community
that spans the world until president
Bollinger propelled me into the Provost
office I was the very model of the 20th
century career that's the model where we
follow the prescribed program of study
or training embarked in a chronic career
we had trained in and stayed there
riesling slowly in the ranks for the
rest of our lives pretty boring but
pretty secure you however represent the
career development paradigm of the 21st
century fewer and fewer people now enter
a profession and remain there for the
rest of their lives rather the
competitive athlete becomes a fundraiser
the corporate executive becomes the
nonprofit champion the marketing
professional becomes a bioethicists and
so on today people earn a degree in a
field and launch their careers for as
long as it takes to discover other even
more exciting possibilities creating by
created by an economy in flux by new
technologies or just by unexpected new
opportunities
many of you have done just that and all
of you represent this 21st century
approach to a career you are at the
forefront of the 21st century in another
way namely in your embrace of
cross-disciplinary the disciplines that
into which modern American universities
are organized were invented in the
doctoral programs a German universities
at the in the late 19th century and ever
since then ever since their adoption in
the United States we've been trying to
find ways to break down the barriers
that separate one from the other some of
the most exciting and important advances
and knowledge are occurring at the
intersections of these old disciplines
one only needs to read the names of the
MS programs whose candidates for
graduation we celebrate today to
recognize that cross-disciplinary is at
the foundation of the School of
Continuing Education Columbia
University's School of Continuing
Education is uniquely positioned to
prepare people for this 21st century
world of work in careers it welcomes
those who want to test new careers those
who want to add another disciplinary
perspective to a base of knowledge
acquired earlier in their lives and
those who want to position themselves in
society's emerging professions we are
grateful you chose to come to columbia
university in pursuit of these goals and
aspirations you have enriched our
academic community and as alumni I am
sure you will continue to do so
throughout your lives we are proud of
Columbia's School of Continuing
Education and the mission it pursues and
we are especially proud of you our
students go forth and prosper stay in
touch with the friends you have made
here and with the professor's you
admired most and be sure to leave the
world a better place than you found it
congratulations to you all
you
I am particularly thrilled about this
year's commencement speaker Commissioner
of New York City Department of Parks and
Recreation the Honorable Adrian Benepe
commissure been opposed work resonates
not only with the goals of several of
SCE mass master's programs his
dedication to protecting and enhancing
the city's natural and historic beauty
for us and for generations to come
epitomizes the mission of our school
Adrienne been apenas career as a teenage
seasonal helper in the East River Park
on the lower east side and then is a
ranger in Central Park between nineteen
seventy-nine and nineteen ninety-five
his knowledge deepened as the scope of
his work broaden through leadership
positions ranging from director of
Natural Resources in horticulture to
director of art and antiquities to
director of the Annual Fund and major
gifts for the New York Botanical Gardens
in the Bronx and then vice president for
issues and public affairs for the
Municipal Art Society in 2002 Mayor
Bloomberg appointed Adrienne benefit
Commissioner of Parks and Recreation
where he now oversees the massive
operation of over twenty nine thousand
acres in nearly four thousand properties
in the park system miles and miles of
beach major stadia and 2.5 million
street and park trees don't know how
that number was arrived by but it's
pretty impressive most importantly in
this role Adrienne betta p has improved
park facilities and programs for
children developed new waterfront parks
and greenways which we all enjoy every
day and all the weekends and made New
York City bloom with millions of new
flowers and hundreds of gardens
currently under his leadership the
department is managing the largest
program of park expansion and renovation
since the nine
thirty's as well as signature projects
to green the city and develop a more
sustainable future along the way Adrian
been appeared a BA in English literature
from middlebury college and a master's
degree in journalism from Columbia where
he was awarded a Pulitzer fellowship he
lives with his wife and two sons here on
the Upper West Side and he likes to run
bike walk and cross-country ski in the
central and riverside parks and
throughout the parks cities park system
so please help me welcome Columbia
alumnus neighbor and fellow traveler
Commissioner with the New York City
Department of Parks and Recreation the
Honorable Adrienne Bennett a
well thank you and good afternoon
faculty family friends and most
important to graduates let me thank the
in Christine bill maher for inviting me
to speak to the all these great looking
master's degree recipients here you guys
look fantastic let me also thank the
people who made it possible for you to
be here today in these warm gowns
parents loved ones spouse's all the
people have the patience and fortitude
and perhaps money to help get you
through this yesterday the graduates of
Barnard College here on the Columbia
campus heard and it's buying a dress
from President Barack Obama you on the
other hand get me the living embodiment
of a TV show parks recreation and while
my presence here may not generate quite
as much media attention as the president
or as much of a security lockdown you
will get around the campus a lot easier
the other thing is the president and I
do share at least one thing in common
all kidding aside we are both proud
members of the columbia alumni family a
family that you are now in a few short
minutes going to be hard
as dean bill Myers mentioned I did
receive my Masters of Science degree
from Columbia Journalism school right up
there in 1981 but my Colombian
connection runs a great deal deeper most
of the members of my family have
attended here in one shape or another I
was somewhat of a faculty brat and lots
of people went here and profited by it
and we promise that once we earn our
first million will give a lot back and I
mean it seriously those of you who go on
to reach fame and fortune definitely
remember Colombia and give widely
because it's sustained by why is alumni
commencements means a lot of things
literally means a beginning and all of
you have heard that before what you have
done here and you're really a great
variety of matches agrees here enables
you to begin again in your careers but
Commandments are also a time to reflect
back and you look back in education you
assess the totality of your Columbia
experience you feel I hope a connection
with the people who have come before you
and will follow you here when I was here
at the journalism school was like you
have a full time job as a one year
program and then when President Obama
earned his BA from Columbia two years
later going to school was also his
primary focus but most of you about
ninety percent of you are studying
part-time because you're simultaneously
working professionals and that engenders
a great deal of respect for me you have
come to this campus where they sense of
purpose a sense of urgency a much more
mature understanding of the problems of
facing world and as much as we'd like to
hope that they are the world's problems
don't seem to be going away they will
require a columbia education to meet
those challenges i am so impressed by
the wide variety of disciplines you have
studied and some of them really do apply
to the work that we do at the parks
department particularly things like
sustainability management landscape
design strategic communications
construction administration just to name
a few we're working on the biomedical
ethics well we'll figure some parks
connection there soon
you are hopefully all pursuing career
goals related to degrees that you've
earned if you want to change your mind
at some point down the road and come
back for another degree that's okay i
will tell you that in from my career
it's okay to change your path and you
should change your path often my
master's degrees in journalism what does
how does that qualify you to be the
Parks Commissioner not on paper but it's
a a winding path with every step of
which I learned something my interest in
parks dates back to my teenage years
some of you in the audience know none of
you getting degrees are old enough to
remember the park system of the 1970s
when things were in very bad shape and
that's when I got my first job picking
up garbage and mopping locker rooms the
lower east side and then later I became
a park ranger when things started to
turn around under Mayor Koch and a guy
named Gordon Davis's Parks Commissioner
I still keep my Smokey the Bear hat
hanging on the wall to remind me from
whence I came and also that only I can
prevent forest fires I left the parks
department to get my graduate degree in
journalism because in those days the
days of Woodward and Bernstein we
thought that's how you change the world
and it still can journalists can still
do that but I had been bitten by the
public service bug and I want to put
that bug in your ear public service if
it's something you get to do is really a
great profession you won't get rich at
it or at least you won't get rigid it
legally but
it has rewards that far exceed those of
any other professions when I went back
in the parks department I hopscotch two
rounds every time somebody offered me a
chance to do a different job for which I
was not even a remotest way qualified I
took it and that included doing natural
resources and horticulture it included
doing art and antiquities it included
doing basic operations and I learned
among other things when somebody offers
you a job just take it and then when you
get it figure it out and find smart
people who know something about it to
work for you I also have the opportunity
to learn fundraising which is a very
important skill if anybody ever offers
you a job doing fundraising jump in it
and do fundraising I did that the new
york botanical garden and also at the
Venus Florida society and then ended up
in my dream job which is being Parks
Commissioner now you can say playing
right field for the Yankees as a dream
job and conducting the Metropolitan
Opera is another dream job I the
scariest thing the scariest word in the
world for me is flyball so I'm no good
in the outfield and I can't sing on key
so none of those work so I ended up in
the parks department so you say parks
and recreation is kind of a joke and you
picked your basketball courts and parks
but it's really much bigger than that
and for those of you who studies
sustainability management sustainability
sort of starts in our parks and why is
this important and why is building the
mission of the school of continuing
education which is sorta just too
compassionate and sustainable global
economy that sustainability part why is
that important it's important because
all of us unless we get our act together
are going to be facing the consequences
of having an unsustainable economy and
an unsustainable lifestyle we currently
have 8.2 million New Yorkers and you are
part of them we expect to add a million
New Yorkers by the year twenty thirty
the whether you believe in global
climate change or not the weather is
definitely getting more interesting
we've had tornados and the snowiest
winter and the hottest summer all in the
last two years with tremendous damage to
the city we also oversee 50,000 acres
between us and the National Park Service
of open space and almost 50,000 acres
incredibly important things are taking
place wire parks so important to New
York
because most of us live stacked up one
on top of the other in tall apartment
buildings we don't have front yards or
bad guys those are our frontiers of
backyards but more important and they
play really important roles is where our
common life takes place the same thing
that homestead Vox intended the
democracy takes place in parks and sweet
16 parties take place in parks and and
great happy moments take place in parks
and gatherings in time of sadness and
great romance takes place in the in the
context of romantic landscapes parks
also play this incredible other function
that we are only now starting to
understand trees and park jinan streets
do these amazing things they take in our
waste product the carbon dioxide and
convert it to oxygen they absorb
particulate matter from pollution they
reduce the ambient temperature and they
reduce the need for running air
conditioners they absorb stormwater they
the shrubs the planet as it parks
absorbs stormwater runoff which keeps it
from going into those combined sewer
systems and polluting our water
extraordinary scientific things take
place in ways that we're only beginning
to comprehend we in New York City have
started to understand the importance of
parks in recent years Mayor Bloomberg
and I want to say how much I appreciate
what he's done as a leader for parks
he's an invested thought it'd be a wise
idea to invest 4.5 billion dollars in
the building and expansion of parks the
largest park expansion program in the
history of the city particularly using
city funds they did a lot of work also
in the 1930s but we've been the
beneficiaries of this extraordinary
dedication to open space and the City
Hall also worked to create something
called plan YC which is a sustainable
development plan for how does the city
grow but still have clean air and clean
water and mass transit that works and
bicycle path systems and requires making
some tough decisions that you get mocked
for the newspapers when you say it's
actually a good idea when people can
ride bicycles safely in the city streets
and you have fewer cars spewing
pollution out and doing the things that
pollution does so we are in the midst of
this first great plan for having a
cleaner greener city of New York and the
parks department is sort of at the hub
of it we're building lots of new parks
and we're adding a million new trees
working with bette midler
and her million trees New York City
program and we are converting asphalt
traffic islands and two little islands
of green where all of that
photosynthesis and the magic alchemy of
turning carbon dioxide into oxygen is
taking place we are also working to
develop guidelines for the rest of this
country in this world of how you build
sustainable landscapes for the 21st
century we work with something called
the design trust for public space and
we're saying that parks aren't or
shouldn't be just beautiful places where
you go when you sit on the bench and
read the paper but they also have to be
healthy ecosystems that are resilient
that are sustainable that are
functioning that are high performance
and landscapes that are doing things
other than simply sitting there and we
have worked with so many professionals
people who are architects and landscape
architects and engineers and
professionals in sustainability
management to do things like add green
roofs to implement stormwater captures
or storm water goes into the ground
instead of into the sewers to take an
old landfill in Staten Island the
largest landfill in Northeast and turn
it into a park these are the things that
we have to think about as we move into a
more sustainable future and those of you
who are in these disciplines you are on
the cutting edge don't worry you will
have jobs in this area so all of these
things come together and many of you are
well into a career some of you are still
still advancing into a career so I will
tell you that one of the smartest things
that you did I believe was to come in
here and say I'm going to get a masters
degree in this area of specialization
because I look at a lot of resumes and I
see that somebody has gone to school
while they're working or taking time out
from work to advance their career that's
the kind of person that I want to hire
and I will give you some unsolicited
advice and maybe in this economy it's
not such extraordinary advice when
you're given an opportunity to do a job
and you think well I'm not really
qualified to do that but they want to
hire you anyway just take it especially
when you're young don't worry about
whether the job fits into your career
track or not because you will learn
something every job I think some of the
most valuable lessons I learned was
working as a busboy in the plaza hotel
because when you're serving people
you'll learn humility and how to
keep people happy and I've spent the
rest of my life doing that so take a job
and learn that there is no job that is
too low or too dirty to do because
having a paycheck is also a good thing
we are sitting in an auditorium name for
Roone Arledge who was very big in the
world of sports and sports broadcasting
so I close with a quote from another
broadcasting legend Tom Brokaw and he
said I imagine this was at a
commencement speech it certainly sounds
like something would say to capensis be
she said you are educated presumably he
was speaking to new about to be
graduates your certification is your
degree you may think of it as a ticket
to the good life let me ask you to think
of an alternative think of it as your
ticket to change the world now I don't
say that to you to make you think oh my
god I've got to go and change the world
but think about this in many ways small
and large as you go into your careers
you have the opportunity to change the
world for the better and everything that
you're doing and if you can go home at
night every day and say I've taken this
opportunity to change the world for the
better even if your salary is minimal
and the hours are long you will feel
better for that I can guarantee you that
so I salute you for achievements and I
wish you the best of luck thanks very
much
and now we come to a very exciting
moment in the ceremony program directors
will now name the candidates for the MS
degree this degree will be conferred
officially tomorrow by President Lee
Bollinger at University commencement and
Greg move member of the SCE Alumni
Association will present the alumni pin
we regret begin with new rajah director
of the actuarial science program will
the candidates for the MS degree natural
science rise and come forward
konstantinos a DeStefano
you King Zhuang Phillip Babcock use ow
yes he Lee
kuan yew chan eric lee pin yay whoo
oswaldo sanchez when losing
Juwanna zoo
and now introduce Robert Wittman
director of the bio fix program
thank you will the candidates for the
master's in science and bioethics please
rise and come forward Jason keen heart
Claudia land
and I'll Ave dr. Meredith Stark Robert
Whiteman
I will now introduce Trudy Baldwin
director of the communications practice
and strategic communications programs
thank you it gives me great pleasure to
ask the candidates for the MS degree in
communications practice to please rise
and come forward
angelique Tyree
Lindsay Marta Leslie Pettersen Ashley
hits nikhyl Tate
eugenia Antonia poo paisa Susan p park
michelle mazzarella
Vanessa Selig know Kristin Danielle
vashi hi there haryana imparato
paul joseph primary
Raisa sofiane
Indrani balakrishna and now it's with
pride in my deep respect I asked the
candidates for the MS degree and
strategic communications to please rise
and come forward
golly nicole pearl chin
Andrea Mancuso
j travis mathew two-mile brady ambler
jordan namoro Amanda Munoz shanique
Finelli ericka suter lamb and and child
Roger Williams sharon s Northman nap or
ragga note Gina smiling ski you let Sara
Ruth dumbrell and holiday claire marie
Stapleton Samantha Choi Joshua
Schnakenberg
zara aziz Veronica Lake Zhu Li Heung
Shan a Randolph Jessie Shinto Melissa
cornick Jeff Dunham Sharon penelo Martha
bell
I now introduce Dennis Green director of
the construction administration
information and digital resource
management and technology management
programs will the candidates for the M
Master of Science in construction
administration please rise and come
forward
Cheryl Farrell kalyani kodly play
bramble Sheldon see Robinson Anderson a
Simon Jason le vine larry was pesky Greg
w Gregory Brooks grace lin Marja
Alexander Nicholas s Murray Eric bishop
Karen beth kery Christopher J Colangelo
christopher Cuccinelli I'm rks Mohammed
Michael ei-chan Frau yelena Goldenberg
wells John Paul column Asano June
Kobayashi soon on Chang andrew hudson
Bueller bayardo Peralta Joshua Howard
robot just myself here will the
candidates for the Master of Science in
information and digital resource
management please rise and come forward
scott speer ski drawn the Randy Smith
Vinson colavita Jonathan stone aw d cruz
steven m gen Grasso Richard H Yoon
taewoong ha Jacqueline outlaw Val cartel
goalie Theo close enough tomorrow's
Rivera Liani snug Elizabeth knife Syria
Marwan guys Tanisha Madrid Bautista
okay and last but by no means least will
the candidates for the Master of Science
degree in technology management please
rise and come forward
second ramicus Krishnan Subin do pardon
Karthik valla javed hook dip in aurora
Janie hurtado Martin via Dennis Gonzalez
Anthony are colino
parag Carnac Alvin a sink Nick ler
Sinclair sorry about that Clarence a
bell so que le wind on Christina are
gone eh Christopher back
Rahim Khan Suzanne de Souza press initio
mccormick arenas c'mon kumar Abdel
murtaza fat equal dippin khosla c'mon
ferreira Geneva's yah Walker chanda pen
Justin Jones Margaret Fairchild Morton
John rosenfeld er Mary Pauline Murphy
Alexander William Miranda Wayne slaven
Peyton Wilson Sean Milligan lover in
bloom fell Christopher Butler Amy are
Lucas
Manuel cop along sooo judge sorority
Randall Lauren Sawyer Colin mccreath
anant on de jose alberto de la Cruz
Edward J lavelle anneal Beckham when zoo
andrew michael van dekhna kal-el
Danziger calixto Perez Galan David
chamoun
I now introduce Lucas Ruben director of
these
mr. popularity Lucas Rubin director of
the sports management and fundraising
programs Dean bill meier faculty and
staff of the School of Continuing
Education family and friends it is my
honor and pleasure to introduce the
candidates for the degree of Master of
Science and fundraising management or
the candidates please rise and step
forward
Leah hyster Carolyn married theresa
Tharp sarah catherine coulomb Jennifer
Schneider Wendy Realmuto Annika dem RS
Samantha young Melissa Pina Sarah
Catherin manraja Judith michelle brown
Mariana Sackler mari el equis and elisa
are rosenfeld Stephanie a crystal malice
Amanda Kessler stacy lynn Vassallo
tomorrow frere Matthew Eric Benson
modesta matos Gooding Leslie Robinson
marc anthony habana Julie Michelle
andriola now will the candidates for the
degree of Master of Science and sports
management please rise and step forward
Eric Mitchell Maya Johnson Danielle
Dominique Martin Isaiah Glen Bryant mark
Luigi cardillo mathew horne Brian Haas
Melissa and Murphy Leslie bush Stephanie
Ruth Casper Michaels Frederick feel
Allison Evans Benjamin and Talbot
sreenivasa prasad naman d Ryan O'Malley
Joshua Jacoby marry our Reyes jr. and
company Ilusha andrew william was Gauri
Jason Francis Noah Falcon Steen Jesse
Jesse William Hendrix the third Adrian
win Clark Jack Anthony Zola last but not
least Louis Barrow Sally
I now introduce Joseph de-spawn
co-director of the landscape design
program the candidates for the Master of
Science degree and landscape design
please rise and come forward you snuck
in their lives luis de su gayness barber
fernandez Lauren Lynch Julia Belanger
Melanie Simon's Martha kazu kezule unas
Elizabeth Boylan is Rebecca giampiero
mcmakin Jean dire Jones yes Judy von
gyal Katherine all
hannah warren matthew rosa and now
introduce craig ervine director of the
narrative medicine program it is my
honor to ask the multi talented
candidates for the master's and
narrative medicine to please rise and
come forward
Chris Cooper hey-soos Rivera Dominic
Decker Robin Kemper Aaron Larkins mario
de la Cruz Jennifer clay tour Shady
Grove Oliver I now introduce Beth
Fischer Yoshida director of the
negotiation and conflict resolution
program will the fabulously facilitative
and constructively collaborative
candidates for the Master of Science
degree in negotiation and conflict
resolution please rise and come forward
except as on
death and Dylan Gerald Jordan Dionysia
Martin's John crazy daniel says oroville
a hose Vincent Lena's lung grits Monica
Casper d machinal Farb Raphael sucker
David Gutzman Alexandria vano blitz Enid
Portuguese at least Bristol with la
familia my quinoa sahar Molly Allen see
Chen Sathya and a GC Yulia rimsky Carl
Jason Allen rebeka coughlin Molina dard
weenie michael ward lindsay he
fitzgerald boubacar my yoga Paulo and a
seat or a morel Meredith Stockman
Georgia ray Thayer
Caitlin Errol blaisdell buck Julia
Eisenberg benenson Shweta demon blahnik
lenina Melinda are Sybil Aquino grace
Hewitt Lisa M Jenkins Lisa Lauren noon
Stephanie Jennings and now it is my
pleasure to introduce steven cohen
director of the sustainability
management program
will be spectacularly sustainable and
environmentally sophisticated candidates
for the MS degree in sustainability
management please rise and come forward
Samuel Abby Natalia Natalia aguero's
Macario Iman Mellie Imam lua al mana
nizar nazanin amarian Sarah bacon
Danielle Baker edward robert bosch the
vaikka piane Renee rano
Emily Briggs Evan Scott Brown lisset
Butkiewicz president jonathan cain
alvaro kangas JD Capuano Brian Carroll
Kathy Myung chung larry chiang allen
Jenji chin Kathy Coburn
Sarah Coulter Jasmine Davis Joe Michael
De Gea's Pablo Freund hi ro h Garcia
Daniel John gia Frieda Sarah guten edge
michael d harris Daniel held I tell her
see car yah yalla I'm close right see on
john tyler johnson who tom Maria Young
jaegerman an us kawa casa wit weena
Ellen kondracki Joanna Florence limone
levy david reed locsin jinan Louie Jacob
Mandel erica vieira Marcos
Stephen Marlon Ryan meinke Michael
Walter Mooji Dina Mustafa Monica Perez
Nevarez Eileen Quigley Pamela Quinlan
Julia ragazzo Ruiz susmitha raava vara
ho robert schwartz robert joseph
Sciortino Julie sure shavon Dianna
Beatrice Sierra Serena sinkler Courtney
and small Luke stats
Linda vray Nicholas Walker Margot Weiss
Adam you Coulson and last but not least
Tanisha McMullen
well now I take great pleasure in
introducing our class day student
speaker Jason keen October 2011 graduate
of the bioethics program Jason good
evening I'm very excited to be here
today and I know all of you are too
congratulations to all the graduates and
a warm thank you to the families and
loved ones who have supported us along
the way in thinking about what to say
today I found the challenge somewhat
unusual as the program's graduating
students today are all quite different
what connects a student in bioethics
with another in construction
administration or actuarial science with
strategic communication or negotiation
and conflict resolution with landscape
design we're not all advancing the same
field or sharing a common discipline we
probably know very little about what
each other has studied but something
does unite all the graduates here and I
think it's a reflection of the school
that's graduating us we all share a
common spirit about our careers a desire
not to follow the well-trodden path but
instead to innovate and customize to
claim our careers as our own and mold
them into something that's right for
each of us to visualize this a bit i
thought i'd share what set me on my
course here at columbia several years
ago at the time i'd grown a career in
marketing I'd learned a lot about the
power of emotional aspiration and brand
building and developed a great respect
for people who combine their intuitive
gut with smart strategic thinking I was
impressed often it often excited by the
field but something was missing for me
part of my personality had been dormant
for too long certain skills and
strengths were ready to rise and shine I
loved philosophy and debate and the
excitement of ideological conflict I
wanted to invest in projects that had
social impact I could see and feel I
wanted to research and write tackling
fascinating questions that are just
waiting to be answered
I spent several Saturdays really
thinking about and writing down my
strengths my needs my passions and my
list became quite long I was honestly
confused and frustrated how could I
construct and choose a singular focused
path and know it's the right choice I
decided to picture myself several
decades from now retired and in my
golden years gazing back in my life I
thought about what which choice would
make me smile fondly and quietly nod to
myself that I did it right that I lived
my professional life to the fullest and
did what I was meant to do that's when I
realized that I simply wanted to do a
lot of different things and that the
assumption that I had to choose just one
vocation was my problem why couldn't my
career firm feel more like an endless
adventure than a mapped out path a
lifetime career that didn't form a
traditional arc trajectory but zigged
and zagged slantways and sideways a
journey that would allow me from time to
time to not just test the waters of
something new but take a running start
and cannonball or belly flop right into
it this kind of professional philosophy
though needs some anchoring each path
should still complement the others even
if they are quite different and so the
trick is to find harmony in what you
pair together and I think it's in
pursuing this balance and creating a
strong overlap where the school of
continuing education really offers great
value the degree programs in this school
are all bridging together and drawing on
more than one skill set or knowledge
base they enrich one area by adding the
perspective of another a program like
narrative medicine brings personal story
telling and subjective experience to the
clinical world enriching patient care a
program like fundraising management
brings the acumen of the business world
to the public champions at nonprofits
optimizing their ability to fulfill
their missions what's really exciting
about this beyond the sense of adventure
and variety that inspires my own journey
is that this kind of training reflects a
modern approach to careers the need for
multiple for the multidisciplinary
perspective is greater than ever last
October the harvard business review
published an article called how to make
yourself indispensable and discuss the
value of the interaction effect evident
in employees who are cross-trained in
multiple functions and skillsets last
April and the New York Times's top 10
list of where the jobs are half of them
involves some kind of interdisciplinary
training and nearly all are a result of
technology advancements making new kinds
of services and thus jobs available
plugging my own program in bioethics
another article in the new york times
last month talked about the shifting
priorities of the Association of
American Medical Colleges as it looks to
integrate more social science training
into curricula in order to protect and
nurture the human side of the profession
in short the marketplace places a
premium on the multi-faceted and
integrated perspective of the very
students who are graduating here today
what joins us together is our knowledge
that it's never too late to reinvent
yourself and a heartfelt belief that
it's actually exhilarating to do so I
thought I'd end by circling back to
where I began brand marketing part of
what makes a brand truly compelling is
giving it an inherent tension in its
personality infusing it with two
attributes that don't typically live
together apple took superior technology
and gave it humanity target took
high-end designers and made them
accessible at mass level prices I like
to think that with our integrated
degrees we're applying this strategy to
our own professional brands a contrast
in our credentials that makes our
perspectives truly compelling so in
summary I believe there is
emotional reward and strategic value in
pursuing an integrated education and I
think that's what we've all achieved I
know we all look forward to learning
about each other's continued academic
and professional success and as you race
to the top of your respective fields I
encourage you to take the scenic route
along the way thank you
before we move to the last formal part
of our presentation I would like to
thank the speakers including Provost
cotesworth who is not here at the moment
but they have really captured the spirit
of the school and more importantly the
spirit of your endeavor in ways that
they did so beautifully and i would like
to all of us to applaud our speakers and
I now call to the podium Leah hyster may
candidate for the MS degree in
fundraising management who will present
the class gift of 2012 Leah
steen bill meyer on behalf of the
graduating class of 2012 it is my honor
to present the school with a gift of
7,500 dollars and growing
leah and graduating students I am deeply
honored by this most generous gift and I
thank you for your commitment to the
school and we do want to keep hearing
from you so you may be graduating today
but you will never leave us just
remember that and we will never leave
you so degree candidates of the class of
2012 Colombia has benefited from your
contribution to life and learning on
this campus now it is time for you to
take your remarkable educational
accomplishment and put it in service of
the greater good continue the Wickery or
work you are doing follow your path and
enrich the world as you have been my
congratulations again to all of you
this brings us to the end of the formal
part of the ceremony but we look forward
to seeing you at the reception on ensel
pop plaza with the audience kindly
remain in place until the conclusion of
the recessional graduates please rise
and now let the music begin